now y'all know I love the spice so let
me tell you about this delicious poblano
black bean quesadilla with a spicy Crema
that is just the most amazing way to
spice up weeknight dinner forget about
plain old black beans okay I'm gonna add
a kick with some poblanos some jalapenos
and some cumin you know I can't make
anything without a little bit of spice
then give them a quick Mash but not too
much you gotta have some texture as if
it wasn't enough I'm gonna make a spicy
Crema with some Chipotle chili powder
and a Cholula hot sauce to drizzle on
top for a little bit of extra heat load
up the tortilla with a layer of cheese
some black beans and obviously more
cheese get a nice Golden Crust and
you're good to go pretty it up with some
avocado and Cotija cheese and you're all
set you can thank me later once you try
this because this one yeah I'm not gonna
share it it is all mine